as you may have heard by now the Trump
administration is currently under FBI
Criminal Investigation and House
Intelligence Committee investigation for
possible ties to coordination with
and/or collusion with Russia during the
2016 election I am still getting
sporadic emails tweets and comments
fewer and fewer but I still get them
saying David the Trump Russia story is
nothing how anyone could believe that at
this point is truly beyond me and
clearly even Trump staffers realize that
the story is more than nothing it has
now been reported that White House
officials and members of Trump's
transition team are purging their
electronic devices to avoid being
potentially compromised by subpoenas to
testify and have their devices looked at
as part of one of multiple
investigations into possible collusion
between Trump and Russia during the
election this isn't happening randomly
because government lawyers recently
ordered all of Donald Trump's aides to
quote preserve any materials that could
be connected to Russian interference and
there could be quote legal ramifications
for staff who destroy evidence relating
to the investigations remember they were
specifically instructed not to destroy
or delete evidence it is often not the
crime pad but it's the cover-up although
here the crime itself could be pretty
damn bad as well and there are people
calling for a total shutdown it's not
going to happen but it's getting to the
point where increasingly we have calls
to not move forward on anything until we
can confirm the legitimacy of trumps
presidency should Neal Gorsuch be
confirmed when the guy who nominated him
might have colluded with a foreign
country and his under criminal
investigation for that I would argue no
and there there are people taking it
even further like congressman ted Lieu
of california saying yep there should be
no there's presidential power needs to
be shut down until trump is cleared
right but there's also basic things in
the government that have to go on and
Democrats being in the minority party
have to pick their battles on certain
things or we've also learned from the
New York Times this morning that Senate
investigators plan to question none
other than Jared Kushner Donald Trump's
son-in-law and close advisor and there
is news there as well the White House
counsel's office was informed
that the Senate Intelligence Committee
which is investigating Russian
interference in the election wants to
question Jared Kushner about meetings he
arranged with the Russian ambassador
Sergey kis lyac who has been the subject
of many of our stories over the last
month or two this is growing I have
every expectation Pat that over the next
ten to fourteen days something major is
going to happen in this story and isn't
this the exact same thing that they
criticized Hillary Clinton for her their
lawyers getting rid of 30,000 emails
writing the hard drive and they would
mana case that if you have nothing to
hide then why don't you just be
transparent i blinking the hard drives
is just that you can't beat that Trump
thought he actually or Hillary Clinton
actually literally bleached the hard row
yeah for people who don't remember
Donald Trump once said that Hillary
Clinton he basically painted a picture
of her at her house late at night in
Chappaqua or whatever pouring bleach on
her hard drives
he's just complete lack of understanding
of everything so at Watergate should
remind us it's not just the act itself
but the cover-up and the attempt to
obfuscate that end up being the bigger
scandal and there's been no shortage of
attempts to obfuscate here